welcome back to Las Vegas now this is an
intense emotional and scary time in the
world especially for us right here in
America I know personally I've been
dealing with feelings of being
overwhelmed and honestly I'll just break
down and cry sometimes part of what we
can do is pay attention stay informed
and consumed and spread everything
that's going on but even that gets
taxing so we have a Family Therapist
descent well mamala
with us to help guide anyone dealing
with that heightened fear and anxiety
right now hey how are you I'm okay you
know as you mentioned it's it's multiple
time yeah and a little bit of an
emotional rollercoaster
so just like anyone else and kind of
just managing myself and trying to do
the work that I can to contribute
absolutely I feel like we have these
emotions but we don't really know what
they are exactly or how to handle them
so let's start with just defining what
anxiety actually is yeah so anxiety is
you know prosaic pervasive sorry
excessive worry and fear the way that I
break it down to clients is saying that
when we think of negative things
happening in the future and we're
concerned about that it can make us
nervous and worried but when we get
stuck kind of over playing these what-if
scenarios and dealing with uncertainty
it leads to anxiety definitely and what
emotions are you seeing with your
clients or just around in general what
actual emotions are you noticing the
most yeah so clients are dealing with
the full range of emotions I think you
know it's heightened to another level
with a pandemic which i think is making
it even harder for clients to and people
in general to deal with the level to
which there is an anger sadness
frustration and maybe gratitude and joy
at the same time it's not uncommon to
experience any and all of them and it's
okay and you mentioned something about
you know the oppressed populations not
being able to deal with those emotions
the same way so let's talk about the
difference and how people are dealing
yeah I'm gonna cover culture in races
those in oppressed populations are not
allowed you know to feel anger
frustration confusion bad
and express themselves based on those
emotions the same way that those in the
majority are allowed to and so I think
even four are challenging because
because of that and what are some of
those pressure releases that we can that
we can do at home or you know that we
can suggest to our family and friends
that are dealing with these types of
emotions hopefully you know feeling any
emotion is okay but hopefully we're able
to channel intentionally those emotions
that we're feeling and have these
pressure reliefs advantage because you
know the things that we're dealing with
aren't going to be fixed overnight
and those might look like things like
self-care it might look like spending
time with your family and friends in my
journaling you know prayer meditation
for those who are spiritual and so it's
really about finding what works best for
you absolutely and how can people serve
other than protesting if they're unable
to for some reason or if they're afraid
to yeah I've had a lot of clients talk
about being in situations where they're
unable to serve for whatever reason as
far as protesting but the nice thing is
that there are so many different moving
parts to contributing to society there's
registering to vote getting involved in
local politics there's you know
organizing they're leaning into what
you're already doing more you know I'm a
counselor so I'm trying to just do that
as best as I can to be there for my
clients that are dealing with these
things and so I think leaning into
whatever it is you're already doing and
educating yourself so that we can keep
being able to contribute to society in a
long-term thank you so much just then
how can people get in touch with you if
they're if they're looking for more
answers I'm most active on Instagram and
my Instagram handle is just cents gems J
AC e NT s GE MS alright thank you so
much for joining us and take care and
we'll flip J and touch